consommer des fraises en mars à
versailles à la fin du xviie siècle
oui c'était possible grâce aux
techniques mises en place
au potager du roi l'office de tourisme
de versailles propose de découvrir
l'histoire et la vie actuelle du jardin
peu connu du public c'est de devenir
profiter de ce jardin qui n'est pas
encore bien connus
même s'il est ouvert au public
maintenant depuis un certain un certain
temps alors nous sommes à côté du
château c'est à la fois un avantage et
un inconvénient puisque beaucoup de
visiteurs viennent à versailles pour
aller voir le château mais je leur dirai
allez faites quelques pas et venez
jusqu'à nous vous ne le regretterez pas
le jardin en toutes saisons à son
intérêt louis xiv fins gourmets et
amateurs de primeurs confia au jardinier
jean baptiste de la quintinie la mission
d'alimenter en fruits et légumes la
table du roi soleil cinq années de
travaux et l'ingéniosité de la quintinie
ont permis au potager de fournir des
récoltes à contre-saison leroy qui
raffolait des figues pouvait ainsi en
consommer dès la mi juin et jusqu'en
octobre
la culture de certains produits
exotiques comme l'ananas ou serre chaude
fait également partie des découvertes de
la visite
l'académie a surtout développé l'art
brut et sur les murs pour profiter de la
chaleur de la bri et puis surtout mener
des expériences sur le lit serre chaude
puisque ici on a compliqué les cdd
production d'ananas
jardin de production et véritable
terrain d'expérience ce potager a
également influencé les pratiques
culinaires de l'époque par l'association
une nouvelle saveur entre histoire et
gastronomie les productions d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui prennent tout leur sens
pour les visiteurs de réconcilier le
passé le présent de voir ce qui a été
fait dans le passé de voir se perpétuer
dans présent grâce à des gens qui se
donnent du mal
près de 400 variétés de fruits et de
légumes récents et anciens sont cultivés
actuellement au potager du roi ces
productions locales sont en vente à la
boutique